[Music]  well y'all reducing dishevel have to do  background yes I'm not rejoicing at all  why I'm sad why are you sad like that's  my ace boon [ __ ] we work out together  she's right down the street yeah  did she come over my house to go grocery  shopping I don't know that I get I get  simple decide oil and keep going chicken  and butter  no I'm did you get I don't do that I  will get condiments well your system get  me she does sodium chicken broth I do  sodium free it's low sodium  haven't you seen skinny daddy I have to  do low Saudi that's what Logan calls him  skinny daddy this is on so much weight  Guinea skinnies did I take my egg I'm  very happy for Vince who's lost a lot of  way he's healthy now like no skinny  would I wanna bones dull growing about  my turkey legs  [Music]  you